[Musique]
l'art et la culture pour lutter contre
l'illettrisme c'est le pari ambitieux
que ce sont lancés pendant près de six
mois les jeunes du RSMA de la 5e
compagnie de formation professionnelle
de Saint-Denis et c'est ce pari qui a
donné naissance à un court-métrage
présenté pour la toute première fois ce
mercredi 14 septembre au lazaré de la
Grande Chaloupe à l'occasion des
Journées nationales de lutte contre
l'illettrisme fruit d'un travail
pédagogique et collaboratif mené dans le
cadre d'un partenariat entre le
département et le RSMA le film intitulé
marma et l'avenir propose une réflexion
autour bien sûr de l'illettrisme mais
aussi d'autres thématiques comme
langagisme se court-métrage j'ai été
vraiment très beau très profond parce
que il parle du patrimoine de nos
anciens ils parlent des problèmes de
notre société de notre jeunesse il y a
toujours l'espoir même s'il y a des
problèmes d'électrices même s'il y a
mes connaissances des fois de notre
histoire de notre patrimoine il y a
toujours des solutions en tout cas avec
les partenariats solides avec le RSM ma
réunion avec le département la région
avec le rectorat ensemble on soutient
notre population à prendre vraiment
conscience de la belle histoire de la
Réunion et de tous les outils et tous
les atouts qui sont à disposition de
notre population et surtout de la
population jeune pour vraiment faire un
travail et de se redonner espoir dans
son projet et donc avec un encadrement
aller vers cette recherche de solutions
et à travers la recherche de solutions
le département a un rôle important un
jour réaliser en collaboration avec le
canal numérique jeunesse Océan Indien ce
court-métrage a été l'occasion pour les
comédiens d'un jour de pencher sur les
enjeux de l'illettrisme qui concerne
plus de 37% des jeunes à leur arrivée au
RSMA alors le premier processus c'est
que c'est que nous en tant qu'enseignant
on cherche toujours des projets des
supports pour donner un sens aux
enseignements quand les jeunes arrivent
ils ont entre 18 et 25 ans certains sont
fragiles et scolaire il y a quand même
un petit tiers de nos volontaires
stagiaires qui ont des profils
d'illettrisme quand ils arrivent quand
ils arrivent au RSMA et notre mission
c'est de les raccrocher au savoir
fondamentaux mais mais en donnant du
sens et donc on essaie de monter des
projets et quand on a eu cette
possibilité de faire un court-métrage on
a donc travaillé avec la compagnie de
Saint-Denis et les jeunes se sont
complètement impliqués de l'écriture du
thème ça vient de et de même ils ont
parlé ils ont parlé identité ils ont
parlé voilà de leur histoire qu'on avait
qu'on avait un petit peu étudié en cours
aussi et ils ont parlé les prismes donc
c'était vraiment une volonté de départ
venue des jeunes de faire de faire ce
lien de faire ce pont entre l'identité
et entre la fragilité scolaire comment
s'appuyer sur l'identité pour aller
au-delà de cette fragilité un projet
concluant puisqu'il aura permis aux
participants de progresser en français
de manière significative plus encore
certains se sont même trouvés une
vocation dans l'audiovisuel c'est le cas
de Romain j'étais dans la filière de
climatisation
j'ai fait une formation d'un moment de
12 mois normalement mais j'ai fait huit
mois après j'ai trouvé un travail le
court-métrage marmaille l'avenir se
rapprocher tout au long du week-end du
17 et 18 septembre au lazaré de la
Grande Chaloupe à l'occasion des
Journées européennes du patrimoine et
sera par la suite diffusé sur le petit
écran
[Musique]